vous ne serez pas étonné que nous
fassions une interview alerte aux roses
ans ne bouge pas pendant le tig
non
on ne bouge pas pendant les jingle bien
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour de faire l'amour pourrait
mais ni l'un ni l'autre
vous êtes 23 alors les fantasmes quel
est pour vous le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte la rue la russie des trottoirs
c'est un bordel un porche nous la rue la
rue
est ce que vous préférez un homme kid
est bien mais qui est infidèle ou un
homme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
moi je pense que je préfère un mec qui
bosse bien
mais qu'est-il l on n'a pas entamé il ya
des mecs qui baisent mal et qui soit
fidèle aussi est ce que vous préférez
être caressé par quelqu'un qui vous
répugne ou battu par quelqu'un qui vous
aime
enfin je dis que j'étais une baleine
échouée qui vous restent gravés et
françois mais carey est ce que vous
préférez que votre mec fasse l'amour
avec une autre en pensant à vous ou fast
amant avec vous en pensant à une autre
compensant une autre ouais ouais c'est
plus sympa clementé rien aucun ne sera
rien de sens que ça arrive ça c'est
comme ça ça peut arriver
j'ai pas de punir
[Applaudissements]
non plus à ce moment j'ai pas de mac
c'est est ce que vous préférez faire
l'amour avec 1000 mec toujours de la
même façon
ou avec un mec de mille façons
différentes 30000 mais clarion s'y
attendait c'est important lassé des
questions mais posé les mines mec
toujours la même façon plutôt qu'un mec
de mille façons un référent mi-mai qu un
remake art book of me marier ces prix là
c'est plus sympa c'est vrai bien sûr moi
c'est important est ce que vous dites là
parce que moi après j'ai mes emails
touche les classes et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux